so to our first subject then and the eu
has been warned that labeling natural
gas as a green investment would miss
emissions reduction targets but
considering the widespread use of coal
responsible for providing more than a
third of global electricity is gas an
important transition fuel um so ella to
you first of all and look at the uk in
particular we do need a transition fuel
don't we as we scale up our renewables
to meet demand and gas really is a lot
better than coal in fact it says here
natural gas emits almost 50 percent
less co2 than coal what do you think
well i mean yes it's undeniable that it
is less bad than oil and gas oil and
coal even but the fact remains that it
is a fossil fuel and if we want to meet
our 1.5 degree warming targets then we
absolutely have to leave almost all
fossil fuels remaining in the ground so
actually investing in natural gas in
into the future is actually more of a
distraction i think personally the
investment would be better placed
actually rolling out and deploying
renewable technologies investing in
smart demand management and battery
storage technology
stanley do you think that's right i mean
if you look at europe for example there
are still some countries that are quite
heavily dependent on coal gas has got to
be an improvement hasn't it should we
see it as a transition
you know energy source
yeah i think we should i've got a lot of
time for for clients i think they've
done some some great work on this
particular occasion i think
you you probably do need to see gas as
having a transitional row the crucial
thing of course is to get out of coal as
quickly as you can not just you know in
in britain but but world over but in
this transitional period i think there
is a case for continuing to use natural
gas of course we actually ought to do
things as well as the classic renewables
you know wind wave and so on and so
forth i would personally i think we'd
like to see a new push on on the nuclear
side as well ella a quick thought on
that
for me nuclear would have been a good
transitional option if we'd done it 30
years ago by the time you know all these
nuclear plants would be up and running
hypothetical ones of course um we would
have missed our targets already so i
think it's a little bit of a red herring
to assume that nuclear could play a role
yeah i think the
error i think they're new technologies
out there on the are they're not new
smaller more effective euclids and all
these things which could be brought
online quickly yeah potentially i think
it would have to be much more kind of
distributed generation which i mean is
the sort of thing we see with solar and
small micro scale kind of heat and power
yeah
and what about what about cost we've had
quasi quarantine the business secretary
today stanley saying that um
given the wholesale this this volatility
extraordinary volatility in the
wholesale gas market he's saying that
renewables will protect us from that in
the future is he right will bills come
down in the future when we're reliant on
renewables
yes i think he i think he is right about
that it is a question of having this
great push for renewals but there's no
way you can have as a whole unless you
get the colossal development on the
battery front you're bound to still need
a base load that is that that is reality
and i suspect that base load has to come
either from gas or from nuclear well yes
and if it was nuclear ella wouldn't that
make it expensive i mean there's huge
costs involved with building nuclear
power plants
well we have 13 no nuclear okay yes and
ella go on
yeah i mean it of course it's it's going
to be costly and we know that things
like solar pv are actually one of them
the most cost-effective form of energy
so personally i think we should be
investing much more heavily in a variety
of different technologies and that gives
you protection from the kind of
intermittency side of things as well as
providing a more reliable kind of base
load as stanley was mentioning
well it's a big topic at the moment very
quickly yeah very quickly on the very
quickly on the battery point i think
that you know
we are in a stage where you know things
like lithium may suddenly become you
know much more much more easily
available and deployable and we may see
a revolution in battery technology it's
such that you know we will be giving
back the renewables maybe giving back to
the united stories you see cars you know
at night they may give back extra energy
back into the system there may be
revolutionary changes here on the
renewable front